نجمه مسلسل النار بالنار تنضم لمؤلفه
وتفتح النار على المخرج
ومات من الخوف حرفيا الطفل اللبناني محمد
اسطنبولي يحزن المنصات عربيه وبالذكريات
والدموع مغردوني ويودعون الراحل فهد
الحيان اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
النار بالنار من المسلسلات اللي كانت
مشاركه في الموسم الرمضاني الاخير وحقيقه
نجاح كبير ونسبه مشاهده واسعه وهو من
بطوله كاريس بشار وعابد فهد وجورج خباز
وغيرهم ومن تاليف رامي كوسا واخراج محمد
عبد العزيز لكن من وقت عرضه في حوله
الكثير من الجدل مو بس بسبب مناقشته
لمواضيع حساسه او جدليه لكن كمان بسبب اخذ
قرض صار بين كاتب العمل ومخرجوا واتهامات
متبادله والكلام عن هذا الجدل اتجدد امس
مع ظهور بطله العمل النجمه السوريه كاريس
بشار في برنامج كلام نواعم وكلامها عن قله
امانه صارت في العمل وقصقصه وحذف واضافه
الاثر اللي كانوا المفروض يتركوه هدول
الشخصيتين هو في شيء عم ينحرق قبل يعني في
شي عم يستهلك مشان هيك بقول لكم انه
الرساله ما وصلت كما يجب وتحولت المقوله
من مكان الى هذا السؤال اكيد انا كنت على
اطلاع على كامل النص ولا نحن تصوير كان
جاهز معنا تقريبا شي 27 حلقه حتى اذا بدكم
شخصيه مريم هي كانت مغايره لما قدم انه
انا كنت ما بعرف انه عم بيصير هذا التغيير
وهذا التعديل وهذا يعني قله امانه من اللي
كان عم يحذف ومن اللي كان عم بيعدل ومن
اللي كان عم بيكب مشاهد ولا قطاط على
المونتاج
[ضحك]
حقيقه كان جدا متعاون بالبدايه وقدم كل
شيء بيقدر عليه وبدل جهد وطاقه كثير كبار
لوقت ما صار الضغط وصار بقى الخلاف يعني
وصل المخرج والكاتب لطريق مسدود فانسحب
برامي بس كنا تقريبا عاملين شيء 24 حلقه
كلام كاريس بشار جاء متفق مع كلام بيقولوا
المؤلف رامي كوسا من اول ايام رمضان وطلع
رمي كوسا في بوست مطول على فيسبوك وقال
انه كريس انصفته وقال ها هي نجمه العمل
تؤكد روايتي وتتحدث عن قله الامانه وعن
السرقه وعن تفسيخ المقوله وعن استغياب
الاخرين وقال انه اللي قالته كريس غيض من
فيض وان هو نفسه لم يبح بعد بكل ما لديه
ويرجو ان لا يضطروا احمد احمق مخادع ما
لقول ما يزيد الطين باللم طيب المؤلف رامي
كوسا على فكره من اول رمضان وهو بيقول هذا
الكلام وكان له كل يوم تقريبا سلسله
بوستات بيتكلم فيها عن تحويل جالس بيصير
في العمل ووجه اتهامات للمخرج والمخرج طلع
مره في تصريحات واكد ان اللي صار في
المسلسف نسف غير جائر لكن قال كمان انه
كان متفق عليه وانه النص اصلا كان في
مشاكل خلينا نقول او كيف ما وصفها هو
بنيويه
وانه رامي كان على اطلاع بكل التعديلات
وصار في اخذ ورد كثير اليوم كريس ووقفت في
صف رامي كوسا اما المخرج فلان مصدر عنه او
عن شركه الانتاج اي تعليق على تصريحات
النجمه
محمد حيدر اسطنبولي الطفل اللبناني عمره
ست سنوات سبب حاله حزن في عموم لبنان
والعالم العربي بعد تداول خبر وفاته بسبب
توقف مفاجئ في عضله القلب خبر وفاه الطفل
تحول لعنوان في الاخبار بسبب قصه الوفاه
فالطفل مات من الخوف حرفيا مات من الخوف
يعني في اللي صار انه ظهر قدام احمد في
حديقه مخصصه للاطفال في صور مجموعه من
الشباب والشابات لابسين اسود في اسود
وشايلين سيوف حديديه في يدهم وكله كده
علشان فيديو بيصوروه لتيك توك المجموعه
مكونه من شابين وبنتين قرروا انهم يمثلوا
مشاهد رعب في مكان للعب الاطفال عشان قال
انه يضحكوا متابعيهم على تيك توك ومحمد
كان الضحيه فبعد ما طلعوا قدامه افتكا من
وجع في قلبه في ناس قالت قضاء وقدر لكن في
اهالي في المدينه بيطالبوا بمحاسبه الشباب
وتم بالفعل ايقافهم بتهمه التسبب بالقتل
لكن عموما وفاه محمد جددت على منصات سؤال
عن الخوف وعلاقته بالموت يعني احنا بنقول
في حواراتنا العاديه لما نوصف موقف مرعب
جدا انه بموت من الخوف يعني او بنقول انه
مت من الخوف كنوع من صيغه المبالغه لما
احد يخاف او يترعب جدا لكن هل علميا فعلا
ممكن شخص يموت من الخوف الدكتور اسلام ابو
سيدو استشاري امراض القلب هو الزميل
الكليه الامريكيه لامراض القلب والشرايين
حيجاوبنا على هذا السؤال اهلا فيك معنا
دكتور اسلام هل نقدر فعليا نقول انه الخوف
ممكن يكون قاتل
مساء الخير سيدتي موضوع كثير مهم وحساس
ويمكن احنا بحكم طبيعه عملنا كاطباء قلب
يمكن بنبه اللي حوالينا ومننبه اصدقائنا
بموضوع الخوف موضوع الخوف سيدتي يسبب هجمه
شديده من ارتفاع ماده الادرينالين وماده
الادرينالين هي الماده المسببه لتسارع
ضربات القلب بشكل عنيف بدي انبه حضرتك انه
هذا الماده
الساده المشاهدين طبعا انه هذه الماده لما
يزيد افرازها بكميات هائله عن حاجه الجسم
المتعارف عليها للاسف بتحس خلايا
الكالسيوم او ماده الكالسيوم على التقلص
الشديد لهذه ماده الكالسيوم لما تدخل في
عضله القلب وتندفع الى خلايا القلب
الداخليه تسبب تقلصات شديده في عضله القلب
يؤدي انه عضله القلب تستمر بضخ الدم
بطريقه متسارعه جدا بدون ما ترتاح للاسف
هذه قد تسبب نوبه قلبيه مفاجئه
وهذا الحديث يعني متعارف سابقا وصارت فيه
عنه دراسات كثيره موضوع الافراز الزائد
لماده
وطبعا اللي بتسبب فيها اللي هو الجهاز
العاطفي السنبثاوي اللي بنحكي عنه والجهاز
العاطفي
للفرح والحزن تفضل الفرح والحزن يعني مو
ضروري انه بس مثلا شخص بيفجعوا او كده
ممكن حتى من الفرح يعني الواحد يموت يعني
احسنت ستي في حالات نادره جدا الحزن
الشديد والفرح الشديد هم حاله من الافراز
الشديد لماده الادرينالين ومن هنا تعرفنا
عن من من 15 سنه قاعدين عم نحكي عن
متلازمه القلب المنكسر اتاكد والمتسبب
الرئيسي في الظاهره للاسف الشديد هو
الافراز الشديد لماده الادرينالين قد
يتسبب بحدوث نوبات قلبيه مفاجئه تؤدي الى
الوفاه طبعا في ناس عندهم قابليه او
استعداد اكثر من ناس اخرين حابه اسالك عنه
دكتور اسلام يعني هل هذا الشيء ممكن يحصل
لازم الشخص يكون اساسا مثلا نقول عنده ضعف
في القلب او مثلا عنده استعداد وراثي او
ما الى ذلك ولا حتى القلب الصحيح او
الانسان الصحيح الصحي ممكن يتعرض لنفس
الشيء سؤال رائع يعني بصراحه اللي عنده
قابليه اكتر هو الانسان اللي عنده
اعتلالات هذا الانسان سواء كان يعني عنده
امراض سابقه عنده ضعف القلب سابق صحيح هم
فرصتهم هدول اكثر بكثير من الناس الاصحاء
لكن حتى الاصحاء يا سيدتي
معرضين وبشكل كبير لهذه الظاهره فيعني
الناس ما يفكروا انه والله هذا فلان كان
سوي
وهو يعني ما حتصير له هذه النوبه لا للاسف
الشديد حتى الاسوياء والاصحاء معرضين لكن
تتضاعف كميه الاصابه بشكل كبير للناس
المرضى او الغير الصحه او اللي عندهم
قابليه سواء اعتلالات سابقه او امراض
سابقه او خلاف انه هذا التوتر او الرعب او
كذا يؤدي على طول لنوبه شديده وتسبب
الوفاه او مثلا لا نوبه قلبيه يمكن النجاه
منها او ما الى ذلك يعني قد ايش الفرق بين
الاثنين ممكن يصير هلا هو نادر جدا اصابه
بنوبه قلبيه انه تؤدي الى الوفاه اكون
صادق معك الا اذا صار اضطراب في ضربات
القلب اللي هو صار حاله من الرجفان
البطيني وما في حواليه حدا للمريض يسعفه
فلذلك ممكن نخسره هذا لكن لو في حواليه
مستشفى او كذا او دائره صحيه او مكان قريب
وتنس زي ما بقولوا شوهد وبدا انعاش القلب
ممكن ينقذ حياته لكن اذا كان عن اي مكان
صحي للاسف ممكن نخسره هذا الانسان ونفكر
بعض انه اتفضل لا قصدي انه في حاله طفل
يعني هذا طفل اللي احنا بنتكلم عنه في هذه
الحاله طفل ما هو مسكين هذا يمكن كان في
مكان بعيد جدا عن المستشفى وصار عنده نوبه
الرجفان البطين الى الوفاه المفاجئه على
غير متوقع انه اصحابه مثلا بخوفوه او
بمزحوا او يتمازح او من هنا ننبه اطفالنا
وبشده عن موضوع الترويع وبصراحه حتى في
ديننا ديننا ينهي عن الترويع لانه هذه
الظاهره طبيه تؤدي الى الوفاه سيدي بغض
النظر حتى اطفال ولا كبار ولا الكلام هذا
كله المفروض ما احد يفجع احد يعني الصراحه
حركه بشعه وسخيفه يعني اصلا طيب خليك معنا
دكتور احنا حنروح لموضوع اخر وحنرجع لك
[موسيقى]
فقدت الساحه الفنيه السعوديه والعربيه امس
احد نجومها الفنان فهد الحيان اللي توفي
اثر سكته قلبيه مفاجئه عن عمر 52 سنه عبد
العزيز شقيق الفنان الراحل كشف للعربيه
تفاصيل اللحظات الاخيره من حياه شقيق فقال
انه ما كان بيشكو من اي مشاكل صحيه قبل
وفاته انه دخل ينام عادي ولما دخلوا يصحوه
وفاه الراحل فهد الحياه مجددت الكلام عن
السكتات القلبيه المفاجئه او كثير ناس
اونلاين جلسه بتقول انه وفاه الفجاه زادت
مؤخرا فهل هي فعلا زادت ولا احنا اللي
صرنا نسمع عن هذه الحالات اكثر ولا في شيء
فعلا في اسلوب الحياه تغير وسبب زياده في
الوفيات المبكره خلونا نستغل وجود دكتور
اسلام معانا ونستفسر منه دكتور اسلام
خليني ارجعلك على هذا الموضوع يعني في
الفتره الاخيره نحن صايرين بنسمع عن ناس
يعني لازالوا انه يعني خلينا نقول شباب او
يعني في منتصف العمر وما الى ذلك وبيتعرض
وكده فجاه بيتوفوا وبعدين بيقال انه مثلا
سكته قلبيه او ما الى ذلك هل فعلا الموضوع
زايد ولا فيش شيء صاير
سؤال رائع جدا سيدتي
النوبات القلبيه انا باعتقادي في زياد في
زياده
هلا حتقول لي والله زمان ما كان عندهم طرق
للتشخيص ممكن وارد هذا الكلام واحصائيات
ادقوا الان الميديا بتساعد على الوصول
الاخبار لكن هي في زياده وهذا مثبت علميا
وزياده في الاعمار الصغيره اللي هم خلينا
نقول يعني خلينا نقول ابتداء من العقد
الرابع من العمر
فصاعدا لما نقول اعمار اربعين وخمسين سنه
هي بصراحه للاسف الاعمار المستهدفه في
البوفيات المفاجئه وتحديدا نوبات القلب او
توقف القلب او جلطات القلب فهي في ازدياد
حتسالي ليش والسؤال كثير مهم الك ولساده
المشاهدين انه الزياده سببها طبيعه نمط
الحياه تبعنا الان التلف عن السابق اختلف
اختلاف كلي بطلنا اول اشي في عنا اضرار
بيئيه في عنا اضرار
يوميا دخان وسجائر والارجيله في مجتمعاتنا
منتشر وبشكل ضخم وكبير يؤدي هذا الافراط
بتناول النيكوتين والتدخين يؤدي الى وفيات
مفاجئه في الاعمار الصغيره السترس نفسه
الستريس احد الاسباب المحفزه لجلطات او
نوبات القلب
وبتعرفي انت كيف نمط الحياه الان الان كل
في عجول الكل يعني صح دكتور بس نحن يعني
هذه الاشياء حتى كمان ممكن تسبب الوفاه
لكبار السن بس نحن اللي ملاحظينه انه
الصغار تحديدا اللي هم كان عندهم قابليه
او يعني عندهم قابليه لمقاومه الامراض وما
الى ذلك اكثر فهذول تحديدا بيتعرضوا لنفس
الستريس اللي بيتعرضوا له الكبار بيدخنوا
زي الكبار بيدخنوا على عكس الكبار بيدخنوا
فتره اطول فايش السر في الصغار
رائع جدا برضو سؤالك سيدتي
دكتور انا معجبه فيك جدا انت رائع يا
دكتور لاني عجبتك كل اسئلتي فانت رائع
كمان هلا
الاسئله اللي بطرحوها الناس يعني صحيح
بحترم اسئلتك لانه هذه الاسئله بيطرحوها
ممكن بس تضعف عضله القلب
فاضله بكونوا شرايينه ما فيهم اشي اسمه
ما بيكونوا مفرعين فرعات جانبيه بحيث انها
تساعده على وصول الدم اذا سكر الشريان
الرئيسي كبار السن بمرور الوقت بصير عندهم
تضيقات مثل الشجره هذا الشريان يتفرع لما
يعطي فروع جانبيه لو سكر الشريان الرئيسي
ما زال هذا الانسان يعني له بالعمر بقيه
لانه يوصل دم من خلال الشرايين الفرعيه
عند الصغير لا تنمر الشرايين الفرعيه
بالعكس هو يعتمد فقط الاعتماد على الشريان
الرئيسي اذا تسكر او اغلق او انصار له
انسداد يؤدي الى وفاه مفاجاه بسبب
الكهرباء المفرطه بالقلب الانسان الكبير
في العمر تدريجيا بسبب تصلب الشرايين
بصير عنده فروع جانبيه من الشرايين
الرئيسيه يعود الى وصول دم فحتى لو صابوا
جلطه مسكين كبير في العمر لا ممكن انه
يعيش وبس يصاب بضعف في الجانب اللي ما
وصلوا الدم من كلامك دكتور اسلام انه
بالنسبه للصغار امور الفجاه تغيير نمط
الحياه هو الحل الوحيد يعني
بصراحه النوم اغلب صغار السن ساعات النوم
قليله الافراط في الدخان الافراط في
التوتر الهرمونات الزائده عن حاجتها نمط
الحياه ما فيش حرق كوليسترول عالي جدا
اعتماد على وجبات سريعه هذه اسباب كثيره
سيدتي
يعني انما ابغى اقول لك كل الزملاء هنا
نهاره الكل عايش اسلوب الحياه هذا للاسف
طيب
معك حق معك حق معك حق ويعني الله يعيننا
بس ان شاء الله ايه والله يعني دايما نقدر
نغير اسلوب حياتنا لاسلوب حياه اكثر صحيه
وهي فعلا هذه الرساله المهمه وشكرا لك على
كل المعلومات المفيده اللي شاركتها في هذه
الفقره كان معنا الدكتور اسلام ابو سيدو
استشاري امراض القلب وزميل الكليه
الامريكيه لامراض القلب والشرايين شكرا لك
من وقت تداول الخبر وفاه فهد الحيان اسمه
ستار ترند سواء على تويتر او جوجل او
فيسبوك او غيره والكثار من النجوم
والمسؤولين تسابقوا للتعزيه في الراحل
والترحم عليه
انطلق في التمثيل من اوائل التسعينات
برصيد وعشرات الاعمال ابرزها طاش ما طاش
وغشم ومع تداول الخبر وفاه المغردين بداوا
في تداول مقاطع من اعماله اللي اضحكت
الجمهور لسنوات
اقول الشرهه ما هي مهيب عليكم
نشرها على اللي يموت عندكم صغيرونه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
انا من زمان ما كنت بس من لما تعرفت على
السعيدات
[موسيقى]
ومشاجرين
قلبي يا ابوي بس يا عمري بس
[موسيقى]
ومن المقاطع المتداوله بكثره كمان اخر
ظهور للراحل واللي كان عبر حسابه على تيك
توك في عيد الفطر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
كل عام وانتم بخير وعيدكم مبارك من
العايدين من الفايزينكم
وغير حساباته الناس وصلت حتى لحساب ابنه
الراحل على تيك توك وتداوله كثير من
المواقع او المواقف اللي كانت بتنزلها مع
والدها وحقيقه هذه المقاطع يعني مؤثره جدا
ورحم الله طبعا الفنان الراحل وتعازينا
لاسرته
[موسيقى]
كان في جح جح قابلني يا اصحابي
وطاحت الجحه
مذهله
ماهي بس
حالي حالي
[موسيقى]
يعني
وصلنا لسيب
روحي في كل شيء
[موسيقى]
يا عسل
منصات التواصل ما لحقت نعود وتحزن على فهد
الحيان الا وفاجئها خبر محزن اخر برحيل
المخرج السوري الكبير هشام شربه جي
والملقب في الوسط بالشيخ الكار هشام شربجي
رحل عن 75 سنه بعد سلسله انتكاسات صحيه
بسبب جلطه دماغيه من عامين الراحل قضاء
اكثر من 25 سنه في الاخراج كان فيها احد
اعمده ومؤسسين نهضه الدراما السوريه
واخرجوا العديد من الاعمال التي تحولت
لايقونات مثل عائله خمس نجوم وسته وسبعه
وثمانيه نجوم ويوميات مدير عام واسرار
المدينه وجميل وهناء واحلام ابو الهناء
وغيرها وغيرها من الاعمال نجوم سوريا
والعالم العربي نعو الراحل عبر حساباتهم
وكثار منهم بداوا يحطوا صورهم وذكرياتهم
مع وجهوا كلام لابنته المخرجه المعروفه
وتفاعلكم او في تفاعلكم احنا كمان بنتقدم
باحر التعازي لاسره الراحل هشام شربجي
وبالاخص ابنته رشا طبعا الله يرحمه ويصبر
العائله
مشاهدينا وصلنا لختام حلقتنا اليوم انا
عدو القاكم غدا ان شاء الله في حلقه جديده
من تفاعلكم في امان الله
[موسيقى]